Hello, and welcome to today's episode.
Today we are gonna take a look at
MeiliSearch,
a search engine database written in Rust.
So far it has taken all the right
boxes for me and I'm really happy and
excited to be exploring it today.
To guide me through our MeiliSearch journey today,
I am joined by two members of the
Meilisearch team, Fred and Carolina. Hello and welcome.
You so Thank
you both very much for joining me today.
I'm very excited.
I think we should start with some a
quick round of introductions and then we'll talk
about Meilisearch and what it is.
Okay. So hello everybody. I'm Carolina.
I'm junior developer advocate at Meilisearch and I'm
here with, my mentor, Fred.
Wow.
That that is a good intro.
So my name is Fred. I'm a director
of developer relation at Meilisearch,
which mean that, you know, I mentor Carolina.
It's one of it's one of my job.
Yeah. But yeah. No. Yep. Yep. That's it.
Alright. Awesome. Well, why do
alright. I've got I've got it. I've I've
got this under control. Okay. So why don't
we start off then with what is Meilisearch?
Who wants to tackle that?
K.
Maybe search is an ultra fast and ultra
relevant search engine built in Rust,
and
you can communicate
to the server with through a RESTful API.
It's very simple.
Yeah?
Yeah. I know. I was I was going
to say, you know, it's it's simple. When
we say search engine, it's not like it's
not a replacement for Google or or I
was going to say AltaVista.
Like, yeah, that that that is that is
saying my name,
my age. But,
you know, it's not a replacement for those
type of search engines. It's really, like, search
engine you're gonna use in your web application
or website.
And
the best part of it is that it's
open source. But, you know, like like, we
like to think that, like, it's really open
source because their way of doing thing is
not just to put the source code and
decide everything.
We include the community. We try to be
transparent as much as possible for decision
or having discussion with the community. So, yeah,
it's it's I would say it's the next
generation search API.
Awesome.
I mean, it's open source. If I remember
correctly it's MIT license, so it's pretty a
very permissive open source project which is fantastic.
I love that it's written in Rust and
you said ultra fast as well. I think
you know all of these things are just
what we want and I'm hoping when we
explore it today we're gonna see this ultra
simple to set up as well. I mean,
I'm assuming with it being written in Rust
we're just compelling a binary and throwing it
around right, it's probably
there's no runtime needed, there's nothing to set
up but is it really going to be
that easy?
Yes. It should. It it should be. It
should be. Like, you can make it complicated
if you want. Like, you know, you can
use it with Docker. You can compile a
search for yourself if you want to. But,
like, if you want to try it quickly,
yeah, it's just the binary, and you're gonna
make it happen.
Unless unless you're not following the instruction, you're
really not good, David. So that but that's
a different story. Yeah. I have been known
to skip a few instructions from time to
time. And I I'm new to development because
I come from another background. I was a
teacher, so
I have
I didn't code for the past years. I
I it's very recent for me.
And
I was quite new to code. I was
coding for a year or two, and I
could
install Meilisearch and get get it to work
very, very easily. So if I can, everybody
can. I swear.
Awesome. I think what we'll do then is
we're just gonna get started. I think we'll
pull up the docs, we'll start working through
it. We'll see what we can start doing
with Meilisearch as we go.
Before we do that, do have question and
one hello. So Peter says, good afternoon. Hey
Peter. Thanks for joining us. Hello Peter. Hi.
And we have a question from Jared.
Is it comparable to Elasticsearch?
Is this a question you get a lot?
Yes. Yeah. In our documentation, there is a
section where we Yes.
So what's it? I mean, we can build
up the docs and take a look at
the answer as well. But is there a
one word answer? Yes or no here? Is
it do people use this to replace Elasticsearch?
Yes and no. In the sense it's like
we we yeah. Yeah. It's it's a little
more complicated than just yes and no in
the sense like we are not a complete
replacement for Elasticsearch,
but for people using Elasticsearch
for the search function
of elastic search, like like strictly what we're
it's the part we're quote unquote replacing.
So I would say we're closer to a
replacement to Algolia
than
a complete replacement to elastic search.
Alright. Well, let's just get started then. Hopefully
we can answer this question as we go
Jared and you can
can make your own decision. It depends like
classic answer and technology.
Yeah.
Okay, let's see. Let's push the magic button.
Three floating heads, one Meilisearch web page. So
the next generation search API open source blazing
fast hyper relevant search engine.
Sounds great to me.
Are people using this and production already?
Yes.
Yes. Yes. So we have a we have
a couple of great users.
Right now the thing is that
we don't have, like, a v one, so
we're still really cautious about the version we're
putting out there. It's still in development.
So people still use this in production,
but, this year, and I don't have the
ATA yet, but we will launch the
quote, unquote official
v one version,
which gonna be, like, even better than what
we have right now, even faster,
and,
you know, taking less resources.
Alright. Thanks. Alright. Let's get the docs up
then. So
this is the getting started guides.
Is the Elasticsearch question here, should we pull
that up quickly before we
start kicking the tires?
There's comparison to alternatives.
Thank you. Let me zoom in on that
a bit as well.
A little bit more real.
Okay.
Yeah. There's a whole section there in the
documentation. So hopefully that helps the people that
are having the same question.
I think what you said is spot
on from what I've read as well. Know,
Elasticsearch does so much beyond just full text
search or text search and most
of the time people are using it for
that really small use case but you're bringing
in all this other stuff with it and
like having something that's just purpose built to
do this kind thing, I think is really
interesting. So that's everything. I I see some
sometimes people are using Elasticsearch like you're using
a shotgun to
cut your picture tables and I'm like, yeah.
So it it's good for use cases, but,
like, more simple use cases, maybe you probably
want something that is more adapted to your
need and that, like, do one thing but
do it well, and probably doesn't cost the
same amount of money too.
Yeah. Definitely.
Okay.
Oh, that's the wrong page. There we go.
Getting started.
So in order to get this started, I
mean you did mention there's containers and stuff,
but I think I'm more than happy just
to curl and shell this right into my
system.
So I'm assuming this is just gonna pull
down a binary, stick it in my
directory.
See, I'm not even gonna read the docs,
I'm just gonna run it.
That's awesome.
Okay. So a couple of things strike me
here. No master key found. What's a what's
a master key in this context?
You can go and care. Master
okay.
The master keys to protect the the roots.
If you want to to set it to
production, you can set the master key.
Okay. So this provides some sort of authentication,
protections from admin endpoints or or search in
general. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Which which you don't
need if you just want to test it.
Yes. Makes sense to me. I also see
Actics server here.
I am a
trying to be Rust developer these days and
I have banged my head against Actics many
times.
So one of the things I'm now excited
for is that whenever I get stuck and
I need to go see an example of
how to work with Actics, gonna go to
the Meilisearch code base, so that's awesome.
Awesome. And
then this is I think my DNS is
just blocking a call to some analytics. We'll
ignore that. So Actually, you make me think,
like, that that should be something you
I'm looking for a word, but, you accept
to, like, send some stats
to be more respectful about people data.
It just gave me an idea to create
an issue for our team.
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah. It's always nice to
give that as a block telemetry or something
like that. And I see we've actually got
quite a lot of flags here. That I
didn't even look at either. So lots of
stuff. Okay.
Let's get it running again and pop back
over to this.
Now that this is running, I'm assuming there's
is there a web interface to Meilisearch?
Yes. In development mode.
Alright. Port seven seven zero zero.
Let's see if it's running.
Tada.
Okay. So I haven't done anything with it
yet. So I'm I'm gonna assume right now
that the the UI really isn't gonna provide
me much value. Is that a fair assumption?
It is. It is. And and you know
what? Let's be honest. Even even when you're
gonna have data data,
out of the box right now, this is
not the most sexy dev
portal.
The good news is that we just hired
a designer. She started actually last week, and
she is amazing. So she will give some
love to those interfaces that are obviously made
by developers.
How big is the Meilisearch team at the
moment?
We are 13. 13.
Nice.
And
soon, 14.
Okay. So Yeah. The team the team's gonna
grow pretty fast in the next year. The
company is is, like, it's working well. We're
still a small startup beginning, but the product
got a lot of traction, so it's it's
going in the right direction.
Yeah. Definitely.
I mean, I think it's just one of
these technologies. I think people have been looking
for alternatives to search engine and databases for
a long time and I think this fits
in and just fills the right gap. So
I'm really excited to see what happens.
But right now I'm gonna try and play
with it. So
it's kind of just jump straight into this
add document space.
So that raises a few questions from my
head now,
does Meilisearch have any sort of
schema or is the schema inferred from the
data I put into it? Do define tables?
What is what
is the structure of the back end? Like
how do I just interact with documents and
nothing else? Do I need to prepare tables
and if not, maybe you can help me
out.
No. No. So You don't have to to
create any tables. You just have indexes with
documents,
and that's it.
So actually, when when when you create document,
like, the structure of the document you're gonna
create or if you import data from
a JSON file,
your, structure of the document will be,
taken from the JSON file or,
the document
on the using JSON format that it will
create.
So if you look at the small code
box right there with ID title,
so you're gonna create document that have those
two
those two values, ID title.
Ah, okay. So I'm gonna assume that the
index that I write to is just part
of the URL that I post this data
to, and that's probably gonna connect the dots
there. So Yeah. Let's see index. You can
see index as, like, separate
database
or separate
separate
silo of documents.
Yeah.
Alright. Well, let's just
well, I guess I should save the first
thing first rather than skipping ahead. So let's
do that.
So create a new file
superman.
So what what what you can do also
is that,
right right before the code you copy,
there is a JSON file that you can
download already populated for you.
If you Oh, yeah. Yeah. Just move it
to JSON so you don't have to unless
you really want to write some JSON, feel
free. But JSON JSON post product, it's probably
gonna be a little bit sexier if you
download that JSON file. Yeah.
I think that's a good idea.
I said, I I usually just skip all
this stuff, so you'll need to keep me
right. So movies.JSON.
Oh, actually,
I think it's pointing on
the getup page, so Oh, it's not really
if you're gonna have access. Yeah. We should
put a rolling.
Raw.
I like that. I'm just taking notes and
being like, we should we should do better.
It's it's perfect.
Alright. Let's
try that again then.
-0movies.JSON
dropping the raw link.
Yep. There we go.
And now we just wanna issue this curl
command, which is gonna populate our database with
this. So
Yeah. And and what you can see with
that comment is that if if you read
the documentation, you're gonna see that by importing
those documents,
using that,
REST API endpoint,
you are, automatically creating a Mendix called movies.
But if you want, you can, If you
check the documentation, you can create an index
by yourself,
and after that, have documents. So in the
case that that index does not exist, Meilisearch
will create it by default.
Alright. Well,
I'll keep it as movies for now because
I'm sure I'll copy and paste Yeah. More
example code and I'll forget to change it.
So I'll just leave it as is for
now.
Now I'm curious if I just pop over
here then and hit refresh.
We have movies now. Cool.
Let's see. Gotta search for the metrics.
May be still
updating. Have documented.
Yes. Check the update
ID status.
So this
this is telling So if you go back
now if you go back, the best way
to do that is, like, if you go
back to the other terminal you used Oh,
yeah. Yeah.
Probably in Versus Code, I think. Yeah. Yeah.
You're gonna see it return you an update
ID.
And, with that update ID, it's, because, like,
the importation is is a sync. So it
would probably be done by now, I guess,
depending on the speed of your computer. But,
like, if you want to check the status,
you can do this by calling
the proper API endpoint.
It's get
indexes, movies,
updates,
and then the number of the update ID,
I think.
Alright. Okay. So indexes,
movies. Updates.
Updates.
And then zero.
Yes.
Cool. Let's put this through a GQ. Processed.
Yeah. So we've just imported
19,554
movies.
Alright. So now now you see its process.
So if you refresh.
Yeah. Yes.
Now the matrix.
There we go.
That one doesn't exist. Oh, okay.
That's just my dig at the second matrix
but I'll save that for an hour time.
So,
I
know it was so subtle even to myself.
I felt I had to explain it
but it's alright.
So now we have a really fast way
to search for movies and a database of
around 20,000
and it does seem quick,
I like it.
So let's see what else the documentation is
gonna run through. Is there anything you just
wanna highlight, point out before we jump back
to the docs? Like, is there anything Try
to try
to search for metrics,
by making a mistake,
like search for, I don't know,
matrix
or metrics.
So this this is a feature I like.
I I call it threat proof because I
I do mistakes all the time. And you
know, this is how search work. You know?
You go to Google search. I don't even
fix my search query when I go on
Google search because I'm like, oh, I made
a mistake. It's faster to like push enter
and just select what Google proposed me after.
It's a little bit like that where like
it's it's typo tolerant.
Yeah. I I do that all the time
on my phone as well where I'm typing
and I noticed the mistake and I think
I'm just gonna go and hit and like
Google fix it and it usually does.
Okay. So yeah, I can type whatever I
want here and
I'm just testing how how much of a
mistake I can make.
Alright. Cool. Yeah. You need you need you
need to be like close. You cannot go
crazy with your mistakes either. But yeah. Okay.
The movie with that guy that I like
in it.
Oh, I I
you nearly got your answer. I I think
the what was the movie you just saw
before?
Oh.
Yeah.
Twelve twelve days of Christmas. It's it's your
it's your preferred film movie.
Well, I've never seen that, but I think
that's definitely gonna have to be tonight's for
you. A Christmas movie in February. Definitely. So
Or Christmas romantic comedy.
That that's promising.
Yeah.
It just seems to have matched each of
those words that I've tied with the overview
of the film, which makes sense. Like this
is coming back. In fact, I've got a
few choice, two choices. There we go.
Okay. Let's see what else we can do.
So we actually, oh, see we've already covered
checking updates as well, so
we don't need to do that and we
can do a search via the API which
I'm assuming is gonna just be very to
what we got back for the web interface.
But
let's just run it anyway.
Nice.
Cool. Alright. Let's see. So we got the
web interface. We've had a quick play with
that too. And then we can integrate it
with our project and we've already made our
million dollar thing and we could move on.
Perfect.
Exactly.
This is a sample like hello type of
example.
But after, you know now you've got a
server working with Meilisearch and get access to
the API, but you probably want to integrate
it within your project.
And this is what I really love because
our integration team done, like, an amazing job.
So if you want to integrate it yourself
and, like, just, like, use the API and
and create a code yourself,
like, good for you. You can do it.
But if you check on the sidebar
on official's a SDK libraries
on the four three links
Okay.
On the top of the yeah. You click
there, and, you're gonna see a list of
the actual integration we have. So, you know,
if you are building something in PHP,
again, you can just like do your
HTTP request and and like call the API
or you can use the SDK
and just use like easy function to do
the implementation.
Yeah. That's pretty
pretty well covered support there. Know, I'll skip
the Java one, but you know, Golang and
JavaScript, PHP, Ruby, Rust.
I mean, I think that's pretty much every
language that I'm gonna be working with these
days anyway. So it's nice to see that
support is just there out of the box.
So those all officially maintained by the the
Meilisearch team? Yep. Yeah. Yeah. And, actually, it's
there there is other integration.
So we have our team like, we have
a team that work full time on integrations.
So, like, more and more front end tools
are coming. More frameworks are coming.
Yeah. We we really think that that's just
gonna make, like, people's life easy, so we
put a lot of effort on that.
Yeah.
And there's also front end tools. You can
say, you know, I use React a fair
bit, so it looks like there's a way
to just drop that in react components, angular
view.
I'm not sure what
instant search is but it
sounds fancy.
And we have Kubernetes deployment manifest as well,
is this
a Helm chart or yeah, a Helm chart,
there we go. Yep.
Is
Meilisearch
horizontally
scalable or do I just run one of
them? Like what is the deployment architecture there?
Yeah.
Right right now it's not. Like, I mean,
we are working on making it hazier
horizontally scaling because right now, there's no what's
the word when
shading?
Sharding?
Sharding. Yeah.
Close enough.
So there's no way to do sharding right
now, but it's something we're gonna work on
because in production, that's gonna be important to
be able to to
use it like that.
Yeah. But I guess it's also retina and
rust fully synchronous through the actor framework. So
I can imagine it's pretty fast and scales
terribly well just vertically. It never remained horizontally,
but it's nice to know that. It is.
It is. Act actually, you know, the thing
that are taking
most of the resources is when you import
document.
So, it's it's taking a lot of memories
to import documents,
but, I would say it's the biggest,
unless you tell me capital I'm wrong, but
I think it's the biggest, usage of resources.
And even for that,
right now, what you see when you try
Meilisearch right now is the actual version we
have, but our developers are working on the
v two of the engine. So the the
like, strictly the engine part.
And, if you think Meilisearch is now, you've
seen nothing. So I I should release a
video soon enough, I hope, of, like, just
showcasing
how much Meilisearch is even faster right now
because now we we're not gonna talk about,
like, something like 100,000
document.
We're gonna talk about, like, 1,000,000, two million
document, and that's gonna be faster than the
experience we have right now. So
it's it's it's just awesome. But now, obviously,
you have to believe me because you cannot
see it, but, yeah, It's it's it's coming
in the pipeline really, really soon. Well, you
seem quite trustworthy, so I know I believe
you.
Also You shouldn't you shouldn't you shouldn't not
trust me.
Well, I pulled up this held chart values
file. I actually see this in the environment
variable. It looks like it disables the analytics
as well, so Meilis know analytics, true. There
you go. Oh I didn't even know Alright
so I'm curious about the,
you know,
I've not really done anything yet and I'm
getting a whole lot back from Meilisearch.
Like you know, I've just imported data and
I could imagine doing this for my application
when I start throwing loads of documents into
the index and then just using it as
a search endpoint. Is there
is everything indexed by default for me or
do I have to tweak the schema in
some way to tell it how to index
and which matters to apply? Like how how
much configuration do I have when I work
with Meilisearch?
Well, do you
you can
customize
what you want to be indexed,
the
what you want to be searchable, the attributes
you want to be you want to be
you want to set a searchable. You can
like, there is a bunch of thing you
can customize. Like, you it's
ultra relevant out of the box,
but you can change a lot of things.
Like, if you want,
here, the relevancy
is, set by the first document indexed.
For instance,
something a word found in the title will
be more important, considered as more important than
a word found in the overview, for instance.
But if you want to change this this
behavior, you can. You can. In the settings,
you have a lot of things you can
customize.
Does that mean there's a curl request I
can send to kinda understand that schema just
now? Will
it print it out for me?
Yeah. You can can actually, you can you
know, all the option you can change is
like you can
have a list of associated word
of synonyms because,
like, we can treat synonyms and you define
those synonyms yourself.
You can have a list of stop words.
Like, as an example, you've seen, like, your
your really long example trying to,
make your product look bad, David.
You know, you've seen I'm joking. You've seen
out, like, all the, like
I don't know what's the word in English,
but, you know, like, those small word that
are in between, like, t h e, of,
buy, those words that you probably don't want
them to be part of your search queries.
So those are call stop words. You can
define them.
Has Carol said, like, the ranking rules. And
there's both things you can do. In the
documentation,
you can see those if you go and
I think it's in reference.
In the API reference,
there is a section called settings.
So if you go at the top level
yeah. Click reference.
API reference.
Settings. Yeah.
Yeah. But you can you can, yeah, you
can see all of them there. And if
you want to see how
use the API to change them, you can
check-in the API reference. There's also a check
a section called settings.
Oh, yeah.
So you were asking how to, can, like,
get the list so you can use, like,
the m deck slash settings. Yeah. Okay. You
you got it.
Yeah. Let's take a look. So
current request to movies
settings,
and
we get back to this. Okay. So we
got
ranking
rules.
Don't know what that means yet. Distinct attributes,
searchable attributes, display, attraction. Alright. Okay. We've got
a fair amount of customization here. I'm
gonna guess what some of this means and
then you can tell me Okay. Where I'm
wrong or whether I'm right. I'm gonna skip
the ranking rules and just let both of
you handle that in a moment because I'm
not sure.
The searchable attributes, think I can maybe work
that one out.
So you know if I maybe wanted to
store
people I meet at conferences in a Meilisearch.
I may want to be able to search
for them by name or a company or
Twitter handle but probably not by email address,
I wouldn't want to expose that. I'm assuming
by searchable attributes I can just say only
allow searching on these certain fields.
Mhmm. That's my guess. That's right.
And displayed attributes is this what if I
pull down,
say I search movies for the matrix, the
displayed attributes will be the only ones that
are returned for each of those.
Do we call them records at Meilisearch or
rows of documents?
Documents.
Okay. But I'm assuming the displayed attributes are
what sent by default, I'm not sure if
I could tweak that.
The stop words, I think Fred's already kinda
covered that a moment ago. Synonyms, I'm assuming
if I wanna call the matrix or translate
it to other languages, would I use synonyms
there?
Yeah.
Mhmm.
Yep.
And I'll leave attributes for faceting up to
you. So if you just wanna tell me
what rank and rules and attributes for faceting
are, I would love that.
Okay.
Ranking rules are the the rules that define
the relevance of the search results.
So it's
it's a bucket sort.
Like, first,
it's by
the results are
showed by
increasing number of typos.
There is also the
how do you sorry.
Like,
my English is not
here at the moment.
The proximity of the words you search is
not the same to search, for instance,
I love rock and
and I love something and rock.
So
the the results are going to to show
in that particular order. The word position,
it's
I'm sorry. I
the attributes,
that is related
with the searchable attributes, this thing I mentioned
earlier.
Like, the
the order of the first document
is in which attributes appear in the first
document, it's important. Something that appears in the
title, it's not the same
as word that appears in the overview because
the title appears first in the first document.
And do you want to help me, Fred?
Yeah. Which one you
you have left?
Which position
and accept
exactness?
Yeah. So, word position is is,
like, it's the result are sorted by, the
position of the query word and the attributes.
So if you go you can even see
example of that.
If you go into documentation and, like, the
learn court
I know right now it's a little bit
all over the place because we we talk
about different topic. But, like, if you could
click on learn,
I think it's a core concept
relevancy
and
if you check ranking row.
So maybe, like, something more visual is gonna
be easier. If you scroll down until you
go to example yeah. So you're gonna see,
like yeah.
There. So you're gonna see, like, each go
up a little bit.
Each tab,
to show you example of, like, those,
those different rules. So, like, if you go
to word position, you're gonna see, like, if
you search for Belgium,
like like
like, is gonna happen, is gonna happen before
Dunkirk because
Belgium app her appear sooner in the attributes.
So it's really like to say, like, hey.
If the, word position is more important to
you, like,
you would have a title like, if you
took if you put this as one of
the,
the more important rule for your search. So
as an example, if there is a a
movie
that is
metrics
colon, how the movie was done, like the
comic documentary on metrics. So if you put
word position as one of the, main attributes
for your search,
that title,
that movie will come first before
the metrics because, like, metrics, the word is
before the metrics.
Does does it make sense what you just
said? Yes. So based what and what you've
just described there, I'm assuming if I search
for Christmas, movies that have Christmas in the
title will show up before movies that mention
Christmas in their overview.
Yeah. So Christmas in the title, Christmas in
the title.
Yeah. So that that's two thing. Like Christmas
in the title
is because
because we didn't set any
ranking rule or,
like,
in terms of the
what do you wanna say something, Carol? Because
no. Because the the
the attribute title is more important than the
attribute overview.
But let's say we are just searching
only the overview is searchable.
So if Christmas is the first word in
the overview, it will appear first in your
search result than if it's the last words
in the middle.
Right. And and because why why title is
more important right now is because we didn't
set,
the rules ourselves, so we go with the
default rules. And because we go with the
default rules,
it means that it will take, the importance
of the, different attributes will be in,
the order
that they are in each document. So each
JSON object. So you're gonna have, like, titles
gonna be more important after that poster, after
that overview, after that release date, after that
junk.
It's the first document. Yep.
So when I search for Disney, I get
something that has Disney as a title, then
I get something that has Disney as the
first word on the overview.
First word in overview, first word in overview,
alright, there's a few and then second word.
Okay. That's done to make sense now. I
think I understand
that.
And I'm assuming if I just pick another
random word like Donald, that should spring up
to the top.
Yeah. There we go.
That makes sense. Got it.
Now there was one more thing, the attributes
for faceting.
Okay. Facets
are like categories
in which you can search.
So let's say you
in the in the movie example, you have
the
genre. You say that in English genre of
the movie and you can just it's a
strange word for me to say. Sorry.
So you can just search in the comedy
type movies or the romantic movies,
etcetera. You can set categories
to search.
Awesome. So I'm gonna throw an idea out
there then. Let's tell me if we can
do this in a timely amount of fashion.
Yeah.
Now our schema here is just a default
because all we did was import movies dot
JSON but what I'm thinking is
and let me test a hypothesis here is
that this will return that movie. Yeah. Now
I probably never want to search by the
poster
URL. So what I'm thinking is could we
modify the searchable attributes to omit
the poster
and
add and the genre as a faceted search
to make it a little bit more sophisticated.
Mhmm.
Yep. Yeah. Yeah. You can do it. Is
is that part of the getting started guide
and I've just like made it up or
no?
No. No. Actually, that's gonna be
let me be sure we have we have
an example for that.
This thing should be no. Searchable attributes. So
if you go
if you go in reference
in settings
and
searchable attributes
yeah.
So feature reference.
Yep.
Our search bar of our documentation works.
Oh, yeah. Actually, search search is is
really good in the documentation because we're using
a software called Meilisearch.
Yeah. It's so good. It's working so well.
I was actually just about to ask if
you used Meilisearch for the search on the
doc. So I'm glad you said to the
YouTube.
Alright. So I could just We're we're dogfooding.
So this
reference page in the documentation is is working
against the same movie set. So I'm actually
not really gonna have to change too much
here. Right? Like I could just
drop this in
and that's gonna give us title, description and
genre as a search.
I think we need to change that to
overview instead of description. Is that right?
Yes.
And
go.
And then I can do my update command.
Where was that? Updates
one,
which I would expect just to see.
Oh, well, maybe not up, maybe it won't
be done as quickly as I thought because
does this have to rebuild the indices on
the index?
That's a good question. I have no idea.
That's fair. Do you do you know, Pavel?
It's
I think
I know it's much better to to set
the in the settings before
indexing the documents.
But
Yeah. But I assume the data will still
be there. It will be just not searchable
because if you change your setting at some
point, like, the document is still there. So
yeah.
Well, we have achieved our first objective, which
is I'm now dropping in the poster URL
and it's not returning anything. So I'm calling
that a win.
Fred's
calling that a win too by the looks
of it.
Alright.
Objective
two is
is there a special operator for faceted search?
Like, can I do an
action or like or do I just type
like, how would I do a faceted search
where I only want action movies?
I don't know if you can do it
from this web interface.
I don't know if it's so. Oh, but
we could do it from the curl, I
guess. Right?
Yes.
Alright.
I'm gonna test out your docs now.
So fast as you search
and see if I can find me a
recurl command.
Okay. So first we have to update the
thing. That makes sense.
Let's
take off director. It looks like we have
that in our dataset.
Not sure.
Alright. And
that seems happy.
I just like running the status of my
update. Someone
has answered a question on whether the indices
have to be rebuilt with a yes. I'm
assuming they maybe have some knowledge here. I'm
not sure.
Dictomy?
Dictal Tommy?
Do we know that person?
Nope. Is it It like it it may
be my boss because he's using a different
username everywhere he goes, so I never know
if it's him.
Do you know if it's Tommy? If if
it's Thomas? I don't know.
Or maybe it's my maybe it's my tech
writer.
Yes. Tommy.
Or it could just be a random YouTuber
who's like, sure. Whatever. Yes. Like, yeah. Trust
me. Alright. That's what we're continuing. And you
know what?
This is this is something I like because,
like, I'm I'm totally fine with having, like,
users that know more than me because, like,
that means that they're using it. Like, it's
perfect.
Yeah. 99.90.5%
of all users know more than me. So
I'm I'm quite comfortable with that now.
Yeah.
Okay. So we've added our attributes for faceting.
Now we wanna do a search returning only
the genre that I want.
Someone else has commented saying, I think it
is Madden post.
Uh-huh. Okay. Yeah.
This guy I know is is one of
the developer on core.
It's it's one of our developers. So thanks,
Martin, for using your real name, so we
know it's you.
Oh, and there you go. You gotta wave.
Hi.
Hi. Oh, I think Nico I think Nico,
Tommy, is is probably
our tech writer.
Nice. Well, thank you for helping out. Okay.
So we've got a carload request here now
and
this is doing a search against our movies
databases, we've added genres as a faceted filter.
We're passing on Thriller as the query.
We don't have a director in our dataset,
don't think so I'm just gonna remove that.
So we're searching for
let me see if I've got this right.
We're filtering on where the genre is horror
or mystery
and thriller
exists on the title or the overview.
Is that what we expect here?
Yes.
Maybe?
Alright.
And let's see if we can confirm that.
Jiku is your friend.
It is.
So we got
the genre match. Now do we have a
thrill? Yeah. And thrill and the overview. Works
exactly like we thought it was gonna work.
That's
really cool. I mean I've got to say
even though we can just throw together some
really trampled
trivial JSON and apply it to change the
way the software works. I'm always really happy.
Like I don't have to dig around and
work stuff out.
Think the
u UX, DX, the intuitive works rather than
having to have preexisting knowledge always amazes me.
I think that's great.
That that's one of the goal we have
when, you know, we build a platform
to as you saw, like to work out,
like, out of the box.
So you don't need to change your setting.
Obviously, you probably want to at some point
to, like, get better results to your users,
but you don't have to. And you can
already try it and and and see how
it's worked really easily.
So, you know, there's something like, there are
some some
what's what's the word in English? Like, is
snobbish snobbish
a word in English? Or some some, let's
say, pretentious
people that are like, hey. You know, software
should be complicated to be powerful.
And I I'm, like, I'm totally like, after
all these years of software development on my
side, I'm like, no. Like, the simpler you
make it, the better it is for the
users. Even if users are developer and they
know how to use those tools, but
be sure that they can configure it. Like
and they can do, like, more sophisticated
or more complicated things. But, you know, when
you look at Meilisearch, it it seems like,
yeah, it's it's simple. Like, it's there's no
there's not a lot of much work done.
And but believe me, there's a lot of
work behind the scene to make it that
easy. But I I think it's one of
the strong point of of using Meilisearch too.
Like, you don't need to be an expert.
Like, if you know how to do HTTP
requests and and use a framework
or
like just use Carol even to test it,
like you know how to use the software.
Cool. Awesome. And you are right. Snobbish or
snobby is another perfectly term Okay. Pretentious. Awesome.
Yeah. Because English English is not my first
language too, so sometimes I speak French and
sometimes I use French word and I say
them with English accent
hoping that it's a real word.
Yeah.
I I speak Scots English, but I do
my best not to inflict the Scottish on
people. So
it gets me into You have you have
no accent, by the way. I was I
was expecting like a
strong Scottish accent.
No. No. No. I keep that for the
weekend.
But
I've got my my work voice that just
it keeps things easier.
Anyway,
cool.
Let's do a couple more things and then
I'll let us get back to our our
days.
One of the things I'm thinking of here
is we have the genres.
Right? Let me search for
yeah. Science fiction. Do we also have
push the wrong button.
I'm not very good with computers. There we
go. We
don't have sci fi like now maybe I'm
pushing something that's not gonna work here, but
I'm thinking
do we have synonym support
for faceted search as well?
No. Maybe.
No. We're not sure.
Actually, I have no idea to be honest.
Shall we try and see what happens?
Yes.
Alright. Let's break things. Alright. So I'm gonna
use your search is really good on this,
I've got to tell you. I'm gonna add
this to my blog,
which has got three articles in it over
ten years, but still.
Okay. So we can add
synonym. Where's my car request? I'm sure it's
in oh, it's not in here. Oh, let's
try another page.
Setting
synonyms.
There we go.
Yeah. I'm gonna try and add a synonym
for science fiction to sci fi.
Hey John.
I mean I appreciate the vote of confidence
but I'm definitely winging it. So
okay.
Let's see.
And I don't wanna add a sweater jumper,
but I do appreciate that example.
I'm gonna add science fiction
and we'll add
sci fi
and sci fi, the weird TV version two.
That look okay?
So
yeah. Look good. And now I just need
to make sure I update the rate
and then Yes. I was going to save
it. Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
We've got we're getting loads of waves today.
Hi, Thomas. We're getting away from Thomas too.
Okay.
Oh,
so Thomas is my boss. And the other
Tommy, I I I checked with him, and
he is he is the tech driver, the
to me. And I I was just been
told that it won't work, but let's try
it.
Oh, well. Let's let's try it. That's fine.
Alright, well we got our update ID, I
won't bother looking that up. I'm gonna
okay, here's a question. I have this movies.JSON
that we've been working with. If I were
to then
change
this sci fi and then reapply that document
over the top. Am I gonna end up
with two copies of Captain Marvel or will
it know and update that record?
If if you keep the if you keep
the same Heidi,
that's gonna be replaced.
Yes. Alright. And I'm gonna change this to
the weird sci fi. Okay.
We're getting away from Sangam too. Hey man,
how's it going?
Sangam. People are chatting today. It's nice.
Obviously everyone's here to learn about Meilisearch.
I forgot what I was doing so we
should just chat.
Oh the movies, there we go. Yeah.
Yeah.
The song.
It
was this one, the post request to index
movies documents pass that to JSON
and that I'm assuming that maybe it's updating
in the background so we can do the
update
for and we also have a question that
we can tackle too.
John asks does this run on stable rust
or nightly rust?
Stable. Stable, awesome. Even better.
Okay.
Moment of truth. The thing that we already
been told isn't gonna work but I'm gonna
try and
The actual channel showed up. Well,
that was a nice idea. So the synonyms
work within the text search but not on
the faceted level. And I guess that's probably
be expected you you suspected that as well.
But you know you know what, David?
If you really want this to be added
to Meilisearch,
I would suggest you to either do a
PR
or, worst case, then submit an idea, create
an issue.
And roadmap. Be yeah.
You
know? But I I certainly see you because
you you know, Rawkode, and you like it.
I I'm pretty sure you're you're you're good
to do a PR.
Oh yeah. Definitely.
I just feel pop out for five minutes.
No.
I I I would definitely love to explore
the code base. I think I I will
be doing that at some point.
But
knows that I'm even thinking about our lives
like would we want synonyms on a facet?
I'm not entirely sure maybe, but
I'll think about it. Okay.
All right, let's try and cover one more
thing before we finish up for today then.
Is there anything that either of you have
you're particularly partial to that you'd like to
show off or should I just pick something
at random again at my random head?
Tell me you have something.
Yeah. Go where I'm done. Let let's have
fun.
Yes. Alright.
So
what's a distinct attribute?
Let's see.
Like,
oh, you should have Susan down or, oh,
that's gonna be interesting.
Oh, it's interesting, but you can
showcase that with the this dataset.
It's just like for
when you have the
a document with
for instance, it's more for ecommerce.
Like, you have a jacket. It's the same
jacket, and you have in white and in
black. And you want when you search for
that jacket, you want just one
document to be
returned.
Alright. Do you understand?
You don't I think that I think that
makes sense. Yeah. So if I've got, like,
assume
say we had in our database, I don't
know why we would have this, but I'm
gonna try and stick to the movies example
anyway. Like if we had different variations of
each movie for the format it was released
like you know VHS, DVD, Blu ray, we'd
maybe use a distinct attribute there that when
I search for the metrics, you don't return
four of them. You just say, you know,
there's one and then there's other variations of
it. Does that make is that right?
Yes.
You you can see, like, if you scroll
up just a little bit, you can see
the example, like, you have a JSON where,
like, it's the two same product. But in
that case, as capital said,
the only difference is the color. So we're
gonna say, like, if you set up the
distinct attribute being,
like, product ID right after you have, like,
that curl
curl, like, code, if you scroll down just
a little bit,
you're gonna set up, like, distinct attributes of
product ID because this is, like, what's gonna
be distinct between those two product when you're
gonna search for it. You're just gonna get,
like, the letter jacket.
Okay. And what would the search result look
like on that? Like I'm getting one back,
does it give me any indication of which
variations exist? Are they omitted from the the
results or does it just pick the one
that it finds and return that?
We don't have an example on that. We
should.
PR
issue.
Well, let's find out. Okay. Let's find out.
Hold on. Let's see. What's our first movie?
I'm gonna copy and paste Shazam and
then we can use the I is the
ID a Meilisearch special thing or is that
just part of the dataset ID?
You need the ID.
Each document must have a unique identifier.
Alright. So for the link, you should choose
another one
because
you can't have the Okay. The same. I'm
gonna apply this dataset over the top and
we'll see that there's also a Shazam, which
is an action and there's one that's a
fantasy because, you know, this is contrived, so
I'm just gonna make this work.
We now have two Shazams with different IDs
and then I'm gonna apply a distinct setting
update to this index
to do title,
and then we'll see what happens.
And, you know, just looking back to the
ID,
by default, Meilisearch will use as your,
like, document unique ID,
any,
like, the first,
attribute that's gonna have the word ID or,
like, the the choose label ID.
No matter if it's, like, UID or, like,
this is my ID
or it's also non
case sensitive. It's non case sensitive, but you
can also define
what's gonna be your
your unique ID if you want to.
Okay. Cool. So I can if I want
to, I can say use something else as
a unique attribute.
Alright. Well, we're now in a situation where
I'm pretty sure I've applied a distinct attribute.
In fact, I'm really curious now to see
what our
if I just pull out these settings now
and take a look at what we're what
we have.
I'll change this to get request.
So we we set our attributes for faceting,
we added some synonyms,
we got our searchable stuff and we have
our distinct attributes set now. Okay. So
in theory, if I
Well I should be able to see this
through the web interface, right?
Shazam.
I only got one.
Yeah. So at least I guess just picked
one of them and returned it.
But I guess we could always
confirm that.
Yes. It's
it's the case. It's gonna return only the
first one.
That that's like with the example capital set
in ecommerce, it's probably because you want you
know, when you go into Amazon and you
have, like, different size of the bottle, like,
you just return one bottle. And when you
click on it, now you get, like, all
the information in your product. So I assume
it's for those kind of use cases.
I'm not sure where when you would like
to use
that setting
not in that type of scenario.
Yeah. That makes sense, I guess.
I'll I'll I'll stop trying to do weird
and random things there. I promise.
No. Actually, it's no. It's fine. It's it's
it's what I love. And it it's also
why I'm happy Carol is there because she's
way more brilliant than me. So.
Alright, well why don't I see.
So anyone that's watching, please feel free if
you've got any questions drop them into the
YouTube.
We're gonna be finishing shortly, so we'll handle
any questions we can before we do.
Why don't we talk a little bit about
the operational side then of Meilisearch? I think
we've covered a really good what it is,
what it does, know, we'll kick the tires
on a few of these settings, we'll work
with the API, everything really just does what
I expect which I think is fantastic.
You know, now I'm
at the stage where I'm like, okay, I
played with it, I kicked it, I like
it, I wanna ship it into production. Like
I just, let's assume I'm thrown onto Kubernetes
with that helm chart and it does its
thing. What about
backup
and restore?
Is that something that's relatively easy to put
together if something were to go wrong?
Yep. Can you repeat please because I didn't
understand
you. Yeah. So now I've got Meilisearch and
production, and I'm curious. Like, I wanna be
able to build out backup and restore processes.
So what would that look like to make
sure that I never lose data?
You can you can search for snapshots
or dump.
Dump. There's two way to
to to kind of, like, get your data.
So creating a creating a dump will oh,
do you want to go, Kettle? No. It's
just a dump is
now
the database is not compatible between versions,
but when you create a dump,
you can
change from versions without problems.
But and snapshots
are you have to use the same version
for now.
So I'm gonna Yeah. So throw out my
naive understanding of that. Please feel free to
go. Oh, please go.
When you when you talk about dumps, I'm
assuming that I'm actually just getting the JSON
representation of all the objects which can be
imported to whatever and the index and is
performed again when I import it. I'm assuming
the snapshot is actually like a
database representation
of all of those documents that can be
migrated to another copy of that database.
Yep. Yep.
Exactly. Exactly. And right now for people that
are listening, we suggest that when you move
from one version to the next version of
Meilisearch right now, you probably want to use
the dumps because
we're not at v one, so we are
still making some breaking changes.
So it's probably the easiest way to go
if you want to be sure you're gonna
retrieve your data.
Starting from v one, we're gonna be really
careful when we're gonna introduce new breaking changes.
But right now, we're still concerned that's, like,
we we like, there's still a lot of
good things to do with the product.
So
we're we're not totally good citizen when it
comes to breaking change right now.
Is
Meilisearch embeddable
or is only can I only run it
as its own binary? Do we know?
Say that again, sorry. Can I embed
like as exposed as like a rust crate
that I can embed into my own
and not have to operate, like, run it
separately or is it always expected to be
run as its own process?
I don't think so. I think I took
suspected that you run it
as an external application.
So as a service
that's a good question, actually.
And and to be honest, I have no
idea because I don't know Rust at all.
Maybe I can get the answer before the
end of the
Alright. Well, we have a couple of questions
from John in the audience. So let's throw
them out just now. His first question is,
does Meilisearch or does Meilis mean anything?
Yes.
It's
the
Nordic god of oblivion
according to an historian.
So
that's why maybe search you need
a search engine to look for the forget
the things you forgot.
Ah, nice. It is it is brilliant, though.
I was not part. You you would think
that I was part of the decision. I
was not there because it's brilliant. But, yeah,
I really like the idea. The the thing
is that what we've seen is is people
struggle to say the name sometimes. So, yeah,
that's another thing.
Just to go back to the unbendable
question I asked
Marie,
and he said, basically, no. It's not unbendable.
So I was not wrong, but it it
was just an assumption. I would like I
had no idea.
Yeah, I'm not even sure if it's a
completely
valid use case for this kind of thing,
but I guess it's always
something that I think is interesting
because databases are difficult, but
okay. Let's go back to another question from
John. He's asked, when is v one planned?
Good
good question. So
yeah.
Actually, I I don't even know what I
could say right now. I said we're, like,
really open with the process, but until we
we won, we kept a little some of
the stuff a little more secret.
Actually, we're in the process of hiring a
PM that will really help us to have,
like, a a better road map, and we're
gonna make that road map public. But let's
say that
it should be around q three.
So we're gonna have, like, alpha and and
even alpha and beta that's gonna be available
before.
Right now, we're assuming that around q three,
we're gonna have to v one.
The only thing that people need to understand
also is that it's not because we're not
a v one that you cannot use it
in production. Like, there's we we have a
lot of, like,
let's say, customers that
are using the product in production.
So it's it's working right now. It's just
that we want to be sure that we're
gonna give and they've done better
experiments with, as an example, with the new
engine, and that we're gonna be sure that,
like, the structure
of our endpoint and everything is, like, quote,
unquote, set in stone for, like, a v
one. But, it's it's coming faster than we
think, and and, seriously, I'm really exciting
excited about that.
You know, I've I started to work the,
quote, unquote, marketing
plan, if I can say, like, what are
we gonna share on Twitter and those kind
of things. I'm like, like, I cannot wait.
Like, I'm like, I I guess the developer
find me a little bit annoying because I'm
trying to, like, move
her earlier when I'm gonna release the version.
So yeah. Because I I want people to
use it as as fast as possible. Possible.
And, like, people that may not be confident
in Meilisearch because
we don't have, like, an official stable version.
So I want to be sure that you
can use it right now, but I want
to have a v one for that exact
reasons.
Yeah. I think I'll I'll just gonna summarize
that in my own little way now. So
I think it's really clear to my head,
but what you have said there is production
ready to use. People should be using it.
It's fantastic. However,
you may need to do a dump and
reimport your data because it's the underlying
database format may change before v one. Is
it safe to assume as the API is
relatively stable? Like if I start building against
them, am I gonna be okay for v
one?
Yeah. Relatively.
So so yeah. Because,
again, we're kind of, like,
making us assumption
would would we're
how can I say that? We're making us
ourselves some caution when it comes to that.
So I would say I would say it's
mostly stable, but maybe things can change before
v one. But, you know, we've been running,
we've we've been duck footing and our
actually, I didn't see a lot of change
when comes to the API. So I think
we're pretty solid. I just want to, like,
put a little asterisk that's yeah. That may
change, but
no. Anyhow,
you you you get a guess of of
what I wanna say. Alright.
It sounds to me that people should be
checking that out if you need search across
any of your applications, Meilisearch is definitely ticking
a lot of these boxes.
I think we've covered a lot with really
showing off the product, we've seen how it
works, we've done a few things that we
probably weren't supposed to do, but fortunately most
of it worked, so that was really cool.
Do you have any final remarks before we
finish up for today?
Mean, you know what? Like,
try it, see if it's if it's good
for you because it may not be the
software for you. But,
one of the things that we would like
your feedback, either positive or constructive feedback.
And, we have a pretty awesome community too.
So, obviously, I would say, Kevin, right now,
is is answering most of the
support question we have,
but also,
in in terms of, like, the Meilisearch employee,
but we have a a awesome community. So
join us on our Slack Slack community,
or, we also use GitHub discussion,
and it's just nice to get a feedback
and and see where that's going.
Alright. Well, thank you both very much for
joining me today. It was a pleasure to
play with Meilisearch and be guided by you
both answering all those questions. I hope people
like what they see, they check it out
and open loads of issues and PRs and
help you push towards that v one.
So again, thank you. Have a great day
and I'll speak to you all soon. Thank
Thanks for everything else. Bye. Yes. Bye. Bye.